devastation at the site of one of the  world's holiest rituals nearly two  million people were gathering for the  symbolic stoning of the devil  hundreds of them have now been left dead  or injured  witnesses say crowd members began  jostling as they tried to reach the  walls at which the stones are thrown the  deadly crush unfolded a few kilometers  from Mecca in Saudi Arabia at Mena one  of the key stops during the Hajj  pilgrimage 2006 brought similar carnage  also in Mena when at least 346 pilgrims  were killed as they attempted to perform  the stoning of the devil at Jamaat the  lead-up to this year's pilgrimage has  already seen a grim incident two weeks  ago more than a hundred people died when  storm winds caused a crane to crash into  mecca's Grand Mosque crushing people  underneath